what's going on guys this is rob and
this video is brought to you by wayne
enterprises so wayne enterprises is
looking for an applied scientist with
the breadth of experience necessary to
support multiple research and
development efforts spanning computer
vision natural language processing and
information fusion the ideal candidate
would be a versatile problem solver who
enjoys floating between efforts to keep
projects moving forward and you will
work alongside lucious fox technical
specialists and clinical experts to
build cutting-edge solutions to critical
problems within the city of gotham and
the world as a whole so if you guys are
interested in this particular position
with wayne enterprises make sure you
guys check out the link down in the
description what will take you to their
applied science division having said
that let us talk about the dc
world needs heroes trailer now
admittedly most of what we saw was just
stuff we've already seen especially when
it came to like the batman right like
the whole thing with catwoman and all
that kind of stuff i mean all that's
that's footage we've seen in the
trailers different things like that even
with the flash to a degree it's pretty
much all the stuff that we saw like the
in production trailer that we got but
here's the question that i have who's
michael keaton playing i know he's
playing batman right like i know he's
cast to play the role of batman
i guess maybe he's supposed to be
playing bruce wayne but as far as i'm
aware the flash movie like the whole
plot for the movie is basically
flashpoint and if it is it wouldn't make
any sense that michael keaton's playing
bruce wayne it would make more sense
that he's playing thomas wayne why
because flashpoint was a story where
bruce wayne died i don't know how many
of you guys ever read the flashpoint
story we covered it over comics
explained flashpoint was amazing so the
idea behind the whole flashpoint event
is like barry allen the flash just wakes
up in this alternate reality and doesn't
really know how he got there he simply
just knows that things are different and
so he basically ends up traveling to
find batman only to find out that it's
not bruce wayne it's thomas wayne and
the reason for that is because basically
when joe chill went to go rob thomas and
martha wayne that joe chill shot bruce
wayne instead of thomas and martha and
so when bruce wayne died thomas just
became like this ridiculously vengeful
guy who actually kills he's he's closer
to the punisher than he is like like
bruce wayne as batman and then martha
wayne snapped she went crazy and became
the joker
yes you heard that correctly
batman's mom becomes the joker
in the flashpoint universe i don't know
that's actually gonna happen it'd be
amazing if it did and there was a lot of
other stuff that went on too and that
whole storyline right for example like
when superman landed on earth he was
immediately snatched up by the
government and taken to a prison where
he was basically blasted with red sun
radiation so he would never develop the
powers that make him superman the
atlanteans are at war with the amazon so
like aquaman and all his guys are at war
with like wonder woman and all her girls
so it's like it's one it's a really
really cool story there's a lot going on
there but how deep this goes i'm not
entirely sure the bigger question here
and i think for the most part this is
kind of an answer this is the direction
that warner brothers is going in that
they're gonna do with the flashpoint
film what dc did with the comics which
is basically reboot right wipe
everything clean and start over again
although there were a few other things
that went on right like dr manhattan
change in the past and so on and so
forth but regardless for the most part
what we saw with the flash it's pretty
much what we have seen so let's kind of
move on from there right let's talk
about black adam because we got a lot of
new footage in relation to like the
whole black adam film specifically the
jsa and we'll talk about the justice
society of america here in a minute
because i feel like that's something
that kind of needs to have some measure
of an explanation we'll definitely do
the jsa explained which i think we may
have already done a video for them over
it comics explained i've i've got i've
got like 2500 videos over there right
it's tough for me to keep track which
videos that i've done off the top of my
head i usually have to look them up and
before you ask
yes there have been times where we've
almost done the same video twice right
like magneto explained and then like
magneto explained in fact there was a
point where my my chief creative officer
gordon had to like catch me because i we
were literally getting ready to do it
twice so here's the thing about blackout
like what we saw there was cool but one
of the things kind of struck me as
interesting so in this whole thing black
adam when it looks like he's talking to
hawkman it's kind of hard to tell he's
off in the distance you know he got the
whole bokeh thing right like the blurry
background all that kind of stuff uh but
it looks like hawkman but he says like
my son believed in a better world that's
why he saved me here's the thing black
adam
kind of does but doesn't have sons
technically his son's names were got and
hurt but they were killed by octon so
here's the whole idea behind this right
so the idea is that octan was basically
a guy who was in possession of something
called the orb of raw which was
basically a staff that had a piece of
like a meteor inside of it but the
radiation in the meteor permeated aktan
which turned him into like the first
metamorpho now for those of you guys who
don't know who metamorpho is and i
always confuse them with amazo amazon's
the one who can copy the powers of
anybody he fights and he usually fights
the justice league so like amazo
basically has all the powers of the
justice league whenever he fights them
it's really really cool metamorpho is a
guy who can basically transmute himself
originally it was any naturally
occurring element and now in more recent
years he can basically combine elements
to make more complex compounds even
things that are not naturally occurring
but basically he's able to become
elements is essentially what it is and
so he kind of went nuts and ended up
killing the kids of like black adam
along with like a whole ton of other
people but the the important thing here
is black adam's kids have not been part
of the picture for a long long time and
even when they were there wasn't really
anything to indicate even going back to
like the power of shazam back in the 90s
there wasn't really anything to indicate
that like his sons had like changed the
way he saw the world so what this looks
like is warner brothers just sort of
rolling with their own origin to a
degree as far as black adam goes and it
kind of makes sense because the way the
rock is depicted in the black adam movie
he looks more like an anti-hero if not
kind of a misguided hero than like a
straight up villain right even within dc
comics black adam's not really a villain
you guys remember we did that video we
were talking about like how the mcu
needs doctor doom and one of the things
we said is how like doctor doom would
like destroy the world before he let
anything happen to his people in liberia
black adam's the same way with kondok
right it's the exact same way where like
he he cherishes his people in conduct
and he'll do whatever it takes to
protect them right like he'll do like
he'll go to blows with superman which by
the way if you guys are ever curious
about how capable black adam is
technically it was an animated movie it
wasn't necessarily in continuity in
terms of the comics but it was pretty
accurate in terms of like its comparison
to the comics there's a movie called
like black adam versus shazam or versus
superman or something like that but
basically like black adam fights shazam
and superman at the same time
and wrecks them both it's amazing
it's a ridiculously great animated movie
but black adam is ridiculously powerful
now let's build on what we saw with
black adam by adding in the jsa then
this is where i say black adam looks
more like a misguided hero as opposed to
a straight up villain because the jsa
are good guys right so like here's
here's a five minute expert right find
an expert explanation whatever you want
to call it on basically the justice
society of america so the jsa was by all
standards of measurement the precursor
to the justice league of america both in
terms of how they originally appeared as
well as when dc rebooted them so when
the jsa first appeared it was way back
in the day right back in the 1940s long
before the justice league of america
showed up and the roster was composed of
people like hawkman different things
like that carter hall as some people may
know him but the the whole point behind
this is that eventually dc got rid of
the justice society of america
technically it was all american comics
but it's all the same thing they ended
up getting rid of the jsa and then
eventually the justice league of america
came along now at that point in time the
question of fans were what the hell
happened to the jsa right i mean this
team just literally disappeared
overnight and nobody knew what they went
to
and it was actually the same thing that
happened with like the original flash
jay garrick and the original green
lantern alan scott and all those guys dc
just wiped them away right they were
just literally being published then they
were cancelled and then like three years
later it was barry allen the flash and
it was hal jordan the green lantern
right they just popped up on the scene
and so what dc did is they created the
multiverse in 1961 with the flash of two
worlds and then they brought back the
jsa but what they told us is that every
comic book story that's ever been
published by dc before the first
appearance of barry allen in dc showcase
number four was basically in an
alternate reality called earth 2 and
they secretly switched over to a new
universe called earth 1 which is where
you get like barry allen and like hal
jordan and all those guys and like the
justice league of america and it went on
that way for decades right the jsa was
in earth 2 the justice league was on
earth 1 and they would cross over right
crisis on earth 2 crisis on earth 1
different things along those lines and
then you get to crisis on infinite earth
and crisis on defending earth basically
wiped away the multiverse the big
problem with this is that if the
multiverse was gone how could the jsa
exist if it existed in another reality
and so what they did is they rebooted
the jsa and this is likely what they're
going to be doing with the team
regarding like the black adam movie so
what they did is they brought them back
in the 1990s and they basically said
that jsa were like a team of superheroes
that fought during world war ii the
justice league of america came along
later but by the time the justice league
came along the jsa had basically retired
right they had stepped down and they
left their you know let like the
flashbarry allen and wonder woman and
batman all those guys step in to
essentially take their place eventually
the jsa came out of retirement and then
you got like the justice society of
america which is written by jeff johns
really really good story but the
important thing here is that the team
was basically retired by the time the
jla showed up i wouldn't be surprised if
that's effectively what's happening here
or if it's one of those things where
like the jsa exists alongside the
justice league but they're not like an
official team right like they're there
but they're not right because right now
the entire dc movie landscape is
literally just just in shambles it's all
over the damn place right so it's almost
impossible to tell what's in continuity
what's not in continuity they are in
dire need of just a clean slate reboot
right like never in my life have i ever
seen a movie franchise that was just so
incredibly disorganized
as that
fingers crossed flashpoint basically
fixes it all but the thing about this is
that the jsa looks cool right like
pierce brosnan is dr fate perfect choice
right adam smasher is amazing kind of a
fun fact and we'll do a video about him
over comics explain as we get closer to
the release of black adam adam smasher
is basically a guy that can increase his
size and density imagine like ant-man
right or giant man is really what it is
right when like scott lane turned into
like a gigantic guy in like uh was it
captain america civil war right like
that's basically what what you know adam
smasher does he his his strength
increases with his size right so as he
grows he becomes stronger and when he
grows like he becomes incredibly strong
or you can just lift like astronomical
amounts of weight dr dr fate is like
dc's version of doctor strange except as
far as i'm aware he's like
way more powerful so it's really really
cool right i mean they have some really
really cool characters here oh this this
is one of the funny things so so here's
the funny thing about that statement
right if i had said dr fate is just like
marvel's doctor strange but not as
powerful dc fans would have flipped he's
nothing like marvel's doctor strength
he's a totally different character but
if i say like dr fate is just like
marvel's doctor strange but way more
powerful dc fans are going to be like
yep
that's exactly what it is
i got no complaint because you are
confirming my views rob
but nonetheless right the entire thing
looks cool um the girl who's wearing
like the green outfit that's cyclone uh
she's actually the daughter of red
tornado red tornado was basically like
an android right he was a member of the
jsa way back in the day so she's more of
like a legacy character and i wouldn't
be surprised if over the course of the
black adam film you may hear some
callbacks to some old school jsa members
right like liberty bell different people
like that it'd be cool to hear about
some of those right like jesse quick
johnny quick you know or whatever the
case happens maybe even like johnny
thunder right like the guy who was
powered by a genie that allowed him to
alter reality he was really really
really powerful and it was really really
cool but looking at black adam just
based on the footage that we see here
especially in comparison to like the
original first look when like he was
just floating up in the air and looking
menacing as hell he doesn't look like a
straight up bad guy and that's cool
because he never really was a straight
up bad guy it was circumstances that
would make him look that way
but he's more of just a guy who wants to
protect his people and if they're really
moving him away from the idea of like
being the ruler of conduct and instead
he just kind of was woken up one day and
he's going out there in the world trying
to make it better then maybe it's
misguided the other part of this is that
maybe he really is just a straight-up
villain because like guys like hawkman
carter hall guy's been around for a long
long time for those of you guys who
don't know about hawkman basically every
time he dies he gets reincarnated in a
different body like he comes back as a
different person uh and depending on
who's writing the story sometimes he
remembers his past and sometimes he
doesn't it depends on what direction dc
wants to go in with his character but
he's been around for a pretty lengthy
amount of time so maybe these are the
guys that are like reeling in black adam
and being like hey man look we get what
you're trying to do
but you're kind of going about it the
wrong way right like i mean we're the
jsa we're basically good guys we're here
to help that kind of thing we can help
your vision come to fruition but like we
got to do it the good way right either
that or maybe like the jsa are straight
up bad guys and i'm not even gonna lie i
would love to see the jsa as like a
villainous team but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
right did you guys enjoy this whole
thing or the the little trailer that we
got and how excited are you all for
black adam because i'm going to be
honest man 2022 looks like it's going to
be an amazing year for the dc film
landscape but in terms of like black
adam
yeah man
i'm already a fan of the rock right and
now it's like the rock playing black
adam
yeah bro
i'm 100 on board with that anyway guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later peace